I'll give one of you 200 bucks if you punch me in the face.
Nah, it's fine if you pussies can't handle it.
Come on!
Oh shit!
Congratulations.
That's for not inviting me you fucking cunt!
LA is the best. I'm making a ton of new friends.
Fuck me.
Hi, I'm Taylor.
Ingrid.
Have we met before?
No.
Do you do this a lot?
Not anymore, really.
I wanna dance I wanna dance I wanna dance.
Okay, you need to realize, it's just a scratch. You can bust that right out.
This is my brother, Nicky.
Hi.
What is this? You don't even like these people.
Nicky where's my phone?
Taylor's favourite brunch spot. Here's a picture of her sleeping.
Those are just a joke.
You're fucked.
♪ Everybody get ♪
We need to be smart.
We're not gonna kill this dude right?
No. We're just gonna scare him a little bit.
Tupac said it'd be days like this.
I'm not a psychopath. I just want to be her friend.
You've been dating a week and he's already letting you borrow his truck?
I just gave him a blowjob.
Damn, girl. You move fast.
♪ Everybody get ♪
♪ oh ♪
Look at my shit!
It was an accident, okay?
Is there anything else I need to know about, Ingrid?
We might have done all of your cocaine that we found in that-
Shut-
Thank you guys. Thank you for your service.